welcome to the man of Recaps this is his
dark materials full series recap welcome
to a parallel Earth similar to our own
except everyone has a talking spirit
animal companion called a demon cool but
it's ruled by an evil church-themed
empire the magisterium not so cool meet
Lyra balacla a rambunctious young orphan
raised his award of Jordan College lives
had a pretty good life so far hanging
out with the best friend Roger the
kitchen boy and her demon panty Lyman
goes by pan yeah when you're a kid your
demon can change forms willy-nilly but
once you're a teenager it settles on one
but now her uncle Lord asriel played by
James McAvoy a super cool Adventurer is
here to visit see he's given a
presentation tonight about the research
he's been doing up at the North Pole
about dust we don't learn what dust is
yet but it's super illegal to even talk
about but he's discovered something even
crazier in the Aurora Borealis there is
a city yeah it's a portal to another
world larva really wants to go with her
super cool uncle on his adventures in
the north but he's like yo I'm a badass
caller Adventurer I don't have time to
be babysitting but soon after Jordan
College gets another exciting visitor
Mrs Coulter who's got a creepy Golden
Monkey demon turns out she's a super
cool scholar Explorer too and she wants
Lyra to come with her now naturally is
part of some prophecy so the professors
give her a cool magic item the
elethiometer they don't tell her how to
use it though so she's just like hey
Siri what's what's up elsewhere in town
meet the Egyptians the nomadic boat
people that night young Gyptian Billy
Costa sees a scary fox demon and oh he's
kidnapped turns out lots of kids have
gone missing lately captured by the
mysterious gobblers in fact just then
Roger gets gobbled up too Mrs culture's
like hey we'll look for him in London
while we go on our adventure so Lara
travels to London to be Mrs coulter's
assistant Mrs Coulter seems real nice
but Lyra does some snooping and finds
out she works for the magisterium
running the general oblation board Gob
yeah she's the gobblers soon they have a
big fight that turns into a Pokemon
battle monkey oh he's got pan I was like
you can't treat me like this my Uncle
Lord Azrael will save me but Mrs Coulter
drops a truth bomb asriel's not your
uncle he's your father saliva runs away
but is captured by the gobblers then
rescued by the Egyptians she befriends
Billy's mom ma Costa who drops another
secret parent truth bomb the reason Mrs
Coulter is so interested in Lyra because
she is her mom the Egyptians aren't
sticking around they've learned that the
gobblers have taken all their kids to
the North Pole so they sell all their
little boats for one big boat and we're
going North now on the way Lara learns a
little more about the elethiometer
apparently you set the dials to the
symbols that sort of frame a question
and then you concentrate on it and it'll
tell you the answer it takes years of
study to even begin to understand it but
Lyra just kind of wings it and she's a
natural now who's this it's lin-manuel
Miranda as Lee scoresby the Texan hot
air ballooner he's a good-hearted
scoundrel with his hair demon Hester
he's here to rescue his friend Yorick
burnison who is an armored polar bear
the town stole his armor though in the
Lyra with their Golden Compass Powers
hey Siri where's the armor so York goes
on a rampage to get it back and boom
armored bear time baby he's Elite and
York agree to come with Egyptians on
their Quest they find Billy Costa hooray
but wait a second where's his demon yes
the magisterium is cutting kids demons
away who knows why but it leaves them as
a shell of a human being and he soon
dies soon after Lyra gets gobbled up
again she gives them a fake name they
don't know she's Mrs culture's daughter
so they put her in with the rest of the
kids but Lyra's getting pretty old they
need to cut her before her demon settles
so they pick her to go next it's only
just then when Mrs Coulter sees her
that's my daughter stops the experiment
she finally explains what they're doing
it's all about dust Now dust settles on
adults but it ignores kids whose demons
haven't settled yet the magisterium
thinks that dust is a physical
manifestation of sin and if it cut kids
demons away before they settle the kids
will like always be sin free and it'll
be an awesome Paradise World Mrs
cultures like so you see it's for the
greater good but it's like yo you're
kidnapping kids and most of them don't
survive these experiments are you the
bad guy she runs over to the intercision
machine turns that thing on full power
and boom explodes it so the kids are
saved and Egyptian's Quest is over but
Lyra is like hey since I've come this
far I want to keep going north and find
my father Lord asriel but that night
they're attacked by monkey bats and
Lyra's captured again this time by
armored Bears they're currently ruled by
the evil bear King who set up Yorick
Lyra thinks quick in our feet and claims
to be your ex demon she's like yeah I'll
become your demon if you beat him in
single combat so York's allowed in he's
like wow girl you're an amazing talker I
give you the nickname Lyra silver tongue
and then it's time for an armored bear
battle except they fight without their
armor on so not as cool long story short
Yorick wins and is now the king of the
Bears who are going to be good Bears now
saliva reunites with a friend Roger and
together they ride their bear friend up
to Lord real super sweet polar cabin so
Lara and her dad finally talk about what
he's doing up here turns out dust
whatever it is comes from the world on
the other side of the Aurora Borealis he
wants to travel through that portal and
discover the real nature of the universe
unfortunately to open the portal he
needs a huge burst of energy the kind
that you get when you split a kid from
his demon yeah poor Roger just can't
catch a break so I was trying to save
her best friend from her father who just
like her mother is gonna kill him for
the greater good but she's too late Lord
asriel oh he goes through with it sliced
off and boom big explosion of energy
just then Mrs Coulter meets him on the
top of the mountain he's like hey my
love forget the magisterium join me
she's made her choice though she's
dedicated to the magisterium so these
two are opposed but they're still super
attracted to each other and make out so
she doesn't stop him she goes home as
Lord asriel travels through the gateway
to another world Larry gets there a
minute later and when there's a shining
Doorway to another world in front of you
you step through it meanwhile we've been
following another kid will Perry from
our Earth his father John Perry
disappeared at the North Pole many years
ago leaving will to take care of his mom
turns out he somehow traveled to Lyra's
world where he became the scholar status
lock grooming this magisterium guy Lord
Boreal found a secret doorway between
our worlds and has been Crossing through
he's got a Tesla parked here to learn
more about parallel worlds he's looking
for Professor grooming which led him to
John Perry and now will he sends some
thugs to break into their house but
Will's cat gets in the way knocks this
guy off the balcony yeah Will's cat just
killed a guy so will Goes On The Run
ends up finding this interdimensional
doorway and so season one ends as both
our kids are traveling to another world
in this world the portal is not at the
North Pole it's in a more tropical
climate and after a short walk she comes
to a city the city seems to be abandoned
but soon she runs into someone it's will
so is these two introduce themselves the
first big shock is that Lyra has a
talking animal companion her demon pan
long story short Lyra and will become
fast friends when he cooks her an
omelette but soon they meet some native
kids who gives them the story this is
the city of sidigase the adults are all
gone because they fled from the specters
these dementor like monsters that suck
out your souls that the kids are safe
they only attack adults much like how in
season one we found out dust only
settles once you're a teenager salira
wants to explore Will's world and it's a
bit of a culture shock as she gets to
see our Oxford which is similar but
different to her own but for now the
elytheometer leads Lyra to a dark matter
physicist Dr Mary Malone turns out she's
studying what Lara's World calls dust
but our world calls Dark Matter Shadow
particles she's just discovered that
they react to human brain waves and
Lyra's like yeah I know all about that
so she meditates pretends to read the
eletheometer and is able to communicate
with them she's like well doc they say
you are super important but I gotta go
right now so she blows this scientist's
mind and pieces out Dr Malone is trying
to talk to the Dark Matter using the I
Ching the Chinese stick based fortune
telling and it works much like Lyra's
Elite theometer but there's kind of a
big extra step in there she finally
programs it to just speak English and
it's like okay so what are you and the
answer comes back we're Angels um like
Angels Angels Mary Malone used to be a
nun so this is a big Revelation for her
but they're like yeah we'll explain
later for now you gotta go cross to the
other world now Lyra and will aren't the
only interdimensional Travelers here
because we've also got from Lyra's world
the magisterium guy Lord Boreal he acts
friendly and befriends Lyra gives her a
ride in his Tesla but then she realizes
he stole the elethiometer she and will
go to confront him where he comes clean
about who he really is and he offers to
make a trade give her the Golden Compass
back in exchange for the subtle knife
it's hidden inside at the top of this
Tower with a tied up old man because
this random kid already took the knife
and this knife by the way is super sharp
and this guy doesn't want to talk they
end up fighting and Will's fingers all
get sliced off but then he's able to
beat this guy and claim the knife and so
congrats Kid the knife chose you cutting
off those fingers is how it shows its
new owner and what makes it so special
it is so sharp it can cut through the
fabric of reality and open doors to
other worlds now the kids don't want to
give this power to Lord Boreal but they
figure they can use it for an
interdimensional Heist steal the
elithiometer back so we'll cut the
window right into his basement he's
gonna grab it but oh Golden Monkey yes
Mrs Coulter is here so now Lyra is
reunited with their evil mom but it's
like I'm not evil I love you Lyra like
you should join me we'll work together
but Larry's like nah you're definitely
evil and so it's time for a demon
Pokemon rematch because Lyra's still a
kid and her demon can change shape so
pan turns into a honey badger and beats
this monkey Lyra and will with knife and
Compass managed to escape just in time
in Lyra's world the magisterium is
guarding the big portal but now the
witches bust in and kick some butt get
on through most of the witches leave to
go find Lord asriel and help him in his
quest but Serafina pekla is like yo
because the prophecy I need to protect
Lyra and Lyra's like hey what is this
prophecy about Serafina pulls a doctor
strange uh if I told you it won't happen
now she pulls out her elethiometer to
ask it what am I supposed to be doing
right now and it tells her something she
didn't expect she needs to help will
find his dad and also searching for
professor room in is our aeronauts Lee
scoresby who heard that he's important
in all this and finally he finds the man
himself and he explains there's a
multiversal war coming between the
forces of Good and Evil they need to
find the bearer of the subtle knife and
get it to Lord asriel because that's the
only thing that can kill the authority
um are you telling me the main goal of
the story is to kill God no no that's an
oversimplification but I mean basically
yeah now this dude has somehow learned
magic he's become a shaman and summons a
wind to get him through the portal and
at this point the magisterium's like
well if everyone's going through the
portal we'd better follow so they're hot
on their tail and these scoresby's like
hey man you go find the kids I'll buy
you time with an epic Last Stand and the
least scores B dies meanwhal Boreal and
Coulter are looking for the kids but
they gotta watch out for the specters
but Mrs Coulter saw how what they do is
similar to The intercision Cutting away
the demons that she was studying and so
she has a theory and she's right the
specters don't attack her in fact she
can control them we don't fully
understand yet how she does this but
basically by embracing the dark side she
can Master it boreal's like yo girl
that's amazing together you and I can
Master interdimensional travel and she
seems into it these two start smooching
but oh what's this oh it was the poison
kiss she's like yeah no offense man but
we're not gonna be partners I'm on a
whole nother level in you and so Lord
Boreal dies now Mrs Coulter finds a new
witch to interrogate like okay what does
this prophecy who is Lyra and she
finally gets the answer Lyra is the new
EVE yes the biblical story of Adam and
Eve and it's like well if the last Eve
ate the Bad Apple and was kicked out of
Eden I gotta make sure Lyra doesn't make
the same mistake meanwhile will Shaman
dad sends him a dream message of where
to meet him so he sneaks off while
everyone naps and this guy only knew he
was meeting the bearer of the subtle
knife he didn't expect it to be his
long-lost son so Father and Son reunited
I'm so sorry I abandoned you I mean it
wasn't really my fault I was stranded in
another dimension also I know this is
kind of heavy but I need you to use that
knife to go kill God but just then a
soldier catches up to him and Will's dad
out takes the bullet for him so they
were reunited for all of two minutes and
now Will's dad dies and now with Lyra
taking a midday snooze totally and
guarded her evil moms like hey wake up
from your nap kid I'm kidnapping you and
also here for a 30 second Cameo is James
McAvoy Lord asriel himself he's making
an epic speech about tearing down the
authority and building a new Republic of
heaven where freedom and free thinking
is encouraged but uh who you talking to
man there's no one here but wait what's
this the Angels show themselves and
they're like yeah we're in yeah we get
the story of how the authority isn't God
the Creator he's just an angel like any
of the others but rules his evil Kingdom
of Heaven through lies and oppression so
now in season three Lord asriel is
flying around in his interdimensional
fighter jet turns out most worlds are
ruled by an evil Church Empire so he's
collecting the best freedom fighters
from every World bringing him to his new
Army the Republic of Heaven meanwhile
Lyra is being held prisoner by her evil
mom Mrs Coulter who's keeping her safe
by keeping her drunk Will's out looking
for her and get some help from two bald
dudes who are like what's up bro we're
angels and guide him to Lyra's world
where will runs into armored bear York
burnison will befriends him by using his
magic knife to cut his helmet in half oh
what the hell bro but the magisterium is
also hunting Lyra they send this new
Young priest evil Jon Snow with a creepy
spider demon to go assassinate her
because they've also learned that Lyra
is the new Eve and they need to stop her
from eating that Apple so will cuts his
way in to rescue Lyra but Mrs culture
distracts him by talking about his mom
and you can't use the knife when you're
distracted oh it breaks and now the
magisterium's here so they got to escape
the old-fashioned way with York burnison
helping him out now they run into a
pixie person here to recruit them for
Lord asriel Belair still hates her dad
for killing her best friend Roger in
fact she's been having dreams about
Roger and is like look I think we need
to go to the Land of the Dead to rescue
him so the blacksmith bear repairs the
knife and they cut their way to the Land
of the Dead which turns out is a real
bad place there is no Heaven or Hell The
Authority has turned the afterlife into
this eternal prison camp but Lyra does
find Roger as well as Lee scoresby and
Will's dad John Perry and Lyra leads a
revolution yo this is not okay it's time
for a prison break will uses the knife
to create a way out and Lyra makes a new
deal with the heartbeat people will tell
them their life stories and he'll guide
them here so Lyra and will just saved
death now instead of Eternal prison you
do what you're supposed to do and go
back into the universe meanwhile Lord
asriel has found his former flame Mrs
Coulter she's like I'm wanted by the
magisterium now I may as well join you
but she immediately betrays him and
steals his interdimensional helicopter
she goes back to the magisterium and
pretends to be on their side but when
she finds out they're making an
interdimensional Spirit Bomb to kill
Lyra she sabotages it but now in heaven
turns out the original Authority isn't
even here anymore it's his Regent
Metatron whose ruling and when he learns
that The Mortals are harnessing the
power of dust which could hurt him he's
like no I don't think so so the Skies
open up and he hijacks the Spirit Bomb
sets it off boom he didn't name it at
Lyra though he used it to create an epic
crater the abyss which is across all
worlds and sucking all dust into it yeah
Dr Mary Malone by the way has mostly
done nothing but she ended up on a world
with these elephant people and
befriended them using the tree sap here
she's built this Amber Spyglass which
lets her see dust and she's been
studying it turns out dust is
consciousness itself so you know a world
without that would be a real bad and now
it's time for the final battle Lord
asriel makes his epic speech we are free
and yeah good Angels versus bad Angels
witches flying around Lord asriel in a
fighter jet Lara and Will made it over
here it's like uh are we supposed to
join in and it's like I don't know I
don't think so on the ground they're
fighting specters but Mrs coulter's like
yo I'm the baddest there is and
disintegrates them after this Metatron
sends her an invite and meets with her
in person as a human like yo girl I like
your style you want to join me and she's
like yeah obviously but Lord asriel
flies in there too unfortunately he gets
confused and fights himself and loses so
Mrs culture and Metatron come to taunt
him he's like Marissa you're really this
evil and she's like well almost earlier
Lord asriel had turned the abyss into a
weapon and now Mrs coulter's Golden
Monkey throws the switch oh epic dust
Spirit Bomb destroys metatron's castle
and now that he's weakened she and
Azrael grab him together and oh off the
cliff even though she was an awful
broken person in the end she truly did
love her daughter Lyra and sacrificed
herself to save her and by extension the
whole Multiverse and so the day is saved
and our main character kids didn't even
do anything they do find though this
weird Magic Cube will cuts it open and
it is the original Authority trapped in
here who's so old he just disintegrates
Will's like oh man I really thought I
was gonna have to shank him but
unfortunately the day isn't saved
because dust is still flowing out of the
worlds our kids don't know that though
so they just go for a nice little
vacation and in fact our kids aren't
kids anymore they're turning into
teenagers and oh it's happening yeah
they start smooching as we've learned
once you're not a kid anymore you start
a track dust to you and your demon
settles pan it becomes this little
ferret thing and will gets to see his
demon it's a cat but more importantly
because Lyra is like the special Nexus
her attracting dust reverses the flow
everywhere yes it's coming back into the
Multiverse but the day is still not
saved because even though they reverse
the flow of dust like it's still
escaping through all the open portals
the only way to save the Multiverse is
to go back to their own worlds and
destroy the knife permanently these two
can never see each other again and so
they do what teenagers do and spend 30
minutes saying goodbye you hang up first
no you hang up first and after one final
interdimensional Kiss Will closes the
portal and breaks the knife for good
closing all the portals down everywhere
and restoring balance to all the worlds
and so one year later Lyra's back in her
world and we never found out what
happened to the magisterium um we assume
it just collapsed and the Lyra and will
never actually see each other again
every year they come to this bench which
exists in both their worlds for an
interdimensional date and so it's a
bittersweet ending as His Dark Materials
comes to an end
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]